it's time to celebrate the women of
country as we mentioned miranda lambert
took home the night's top prize but she
missed her first ever acm awards in 17
years due to a prior commitment overseas
in london but miranda still gave a
virtual acceptance speech where she paid
tribute to all the women out there take
a look
i've been waiting for this for a really
really long time um
i actually never thought it would happen
but thank you so much to the country
music family for
embracing me all these years and
continuing to support me
in the academy for everything this one
goes out to all the singer songwriter
girls out there that are putting their
blood sweat and tears into their guitar
strings
we did it this is for us
all right the women in country music are
definitely each other's biggest
cheerleaders with carly pierce and
carrie underwood celebrating miranda's
big win backstage
i feel like for the last year i've been
saying the ladies are here to stay and i
feel like
i'm just so proud to be in this class of
women it it just feels so good to see
people that i admire and also people
that i've championed
win
miranda's long overdue
for winning this award so i couldn't be
more proud of her as a sister in
this genre of music in this industry
so yeah i mean there were a lot of
incredible females on stage tonight and
i look forward to more of that happening
i mean this has been in the works for a
while do you think female representation
in country music is improving
you know this is where we talk about
that what do you think
listen it's hard to say what's
performative right like that's always
the issue with everything uh just with
what the chicks have gone through in in
retro like when we're speaking about
morgan wall and you know morgan wallin
was forgiven faster than the chicks and
what morgan did was insane what the
chick said
anyway
point is
i think i will see an improvement for
female representation in country music
when more women are played on the
stations um i think this award showed
like 17 years miranda is now finally
winning this award thank i'm just so
thankful that she won it but it is long
overdue and i'm hoping that it's not
just an award show it's going to be you
know shared across the entire board
because it needs to be equal it can't
just be just the men owning the country
music genre like we need to see more
women so i'm hoping this ignites
something and and like carrie underwood
said more
yeah well and i think that also means
that women have to consume more like i
think that you know when you're when
you're downloading download those
women's albums like we need to be seeing
more of that and there needs to be more
noise behind those women like it's very
exciting that this happened for miranda
but it's kind of sad that it's taken
this long
and it's like
not enough
but
again happy for her for sure